Imagine this your aircraft has state-of-the-art avionics
But your map is from the 15th century commanded by please advise
Neuroscientists are stuck in this harrowing predicament as they try to make their way around the human brain the first
Classical map made about a century ago it is still widely used today
published in 1909 it defined regions on the pinkish gray organ that control our actions and
Functions the fundamental unit of brain organization for the cerebral cortex is what we call a cortical area
So on the map you could say there's a country called speech and under called short-term memory another hand movement
Identifying every one of these cortical areas became a major objective of the human connectome project the HCP
meeting the effort a master map maker
I consider myself a cortical cartographer by July of last year the HCP completed its first phase a
21st century world map of the brain we reported the presence of 180 distinct cortical areas
97 of them were new to brain science the connectome gives us this opportunity a really great tool to be able to navigate
the human brain
Navigating the brain is more than just naming cities and states
You need to understand the connections between them
the word connect home implies that the fundamentally important thing about brains is
Connections this evening. We'll be talking and learning about two different kinds of connections
structural connections in the brain
versus functional connections in the brain by structural connections
We're really time at the physical connections of wires that connect nerve cells
so structural connectivity looks at the regions and the pathway is connecting them the functional connectivity though is more about
How different parts of the brain?
work together on an ongoing basis brain function arises from conversations that different brain regions are having with each other a
functional map must track living data
conversations flowing through the pathways between brain regions
We collected data from 1200 individuals when you have them do different tasks in the scanner things like a memory task
Emotions on faces those same regions of the brain seem to be forming networks brain structure
Is wired by its experience but we have no idea in what form that wiring
diagram has that information and
That's the big puzzle to see how that translates into individual nerve connections
you need to look much closer than David or Deanna's technology can go down to the level of individual neurons to
Quadrillion times smaller, what exactly is 2?
Quadrillion times smaller. Well, Jeff's covering would be a city about the size of say
Sheboygan Wisconsin that little blur that little blob there might be Sheboygan are not sure
That little blob is a 1 millimeter cube of brain tissue and it contains a staggering number of neurons
50,000 nerve cells and about 1 billion
Synapses. So right now there's no way to model an entire human brain by diagramming its micro wiring
Scientifically for now were lost in the foggy limits of brain science
It would need more digital information than is the actual digital content of the world